como una manera de combatir la violencia
el presidente de Ecuador anunció tres
medidas urgentes para hacer frente al
imparable aumento de la delincuencia el
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado en
el país una de las que más sorprendió
fue la autorización de la tenencia y
porte de armas para la población civil
se autoriza la tenencia y porte de armas
de uso civil para defensa personal de
acuerdo con los requisitos de ley y el
reglamento soy inocente este anuncio se
da en medio de la crisis política que
enfrenta el mandatario y el asombro que
produjo la noticia sobre el
fallecimiento del empresario Rubén
charrés uno de los Implicados En el
presunto caso de corrupción por el que
el presidente Guillermo lasso será
llevado a juicio político dentro de los
requisitos para aportar armas se
encuentra tener al menos 25 años de edad
obtener certificados psicológicos y
toxicológicos no tener antecedentes
judiciales entre otros también se
autorizó el uso de de gas pimienta pero
se prohibió la fabricación artesanal de
armas plazo anunció las nuevas medidas
tras hechos violentos registrados
Durante los últimos días como el
abandono de una cabeza humana el asalto
a un banco en Guayaquil y el secuestro
de un hombre que posteriormente fue
encontrado con un artefacto explosivo
atada a su cuerpo además de los
numerosos casos de asesinatos y
extorsiones
ocupante la situación que vive el
Ecuador tiene es bastante preocupante
porque la violencia escalado a niveles
inimaginables tenemos o contamos
diariamente con asesinatos con robos con
extorsiones a negocios dentro de las
medidas también se encuentran controles
y registros informáticos y un estado de
excepción con toque de queda en la
provincia costera de guayas y las
provincias de Santa Elena y los ríos
además de un apoyo de seguridad privada
para la Policía Nacional